an activist screams at tucker carlson in
front of his daughter at a fishing store
and
the democrats can't let america go back
to normal i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you
gotten a vpn yet visit expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first here is your
reminder
if you are with verizon at z t mobile
you are paying too much money every
month pure talk usa you should be
switching over because you could be
saving your family over 800
a year it's the same great coverage
because pure talk is on the exact same
network as one of the big three
but at a fraction of the price switching
is as easy as switching out your sim
card you can keep your phone keep your
number or get huge discounts on the
latest iphones and androids plus
right now you can get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month
i know what you're saying to yourself
what if i use more than six gigs of data
this month well here's the good news
they're not going to charge you for it
there's a reason that pure talk is the
highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs
why they are the preferred wireless
partner of amac a lot of phone companies
won't tell you exactly what you are
getting for your money they'll give you
a
big rolodex of all the things that
you're getting without actually
explaining what any of that means not so
with pure talk usa
go to puretalk usa get exactly what you
need a limited talk six gigs of data 30
bucks a month and if you go over
they won't charge you for it from your
cell phone dial pound 250 save my name
ben shapiro
save an additional 50 off your very
first month that is pound 2 5
0 say ben shapiro once more dial pound 2
5 0
and say my name ben shapiro to get 50
off your very first month
of coverage alrighty so over the weekend
there was this viral video that was
going around
it was a video of a person named dan
bailey
who's i guess a fly fishing guide in
montana
and he posted this video himself which
means this was not taken
really by a third party who then posted
it this is a person who is very very
proud of himself he saw tucker carlson
the fox news host
in montana at a fly fishing shop and he
just started berating him
and apparently tucker's daughter was
there and this guy doesn't care
and the left on twitter particularly but
also in the media
seem to believe that this guy is is
committing an act of heroism that this
guy has done something wonderful
and good for the country by confronting
tucker carlson and frankly acting like a
jerk
here is a little bit of the tape i don't
care man
okay just dude you are my worst human
being
i want you
[Music]
what you have done to everybody else
okay so what he's actually saying if you
can't hear it is that
he is he's telling him he doesn't care
if he his daughter is there he says
dude you are the worst human being known
to mankind i want you to know that what
you've done to the states of the united
states to everything else in the world i
don't care your daughter's here what
you've done to people's families what
you've done
to everyone else in the world and uh
tucker
tries to defuse it if you've seen tucker
in these sorts of situations tucker is
pretty calm and tucker's been confronted
many times in public
at this point he handles it really well
and as somebody who's been confronted a
couple of times in public
i can say it's not always the easiest
thing in the world i remember one time i
was at a public park and i was holding
my then five-year-old daughter in my
arms and somebody came up and said how
do you
sleep at night i was like you know what
i'm not gonna do this and i sort of
walked away that's sort of what tucker
does here right he handles this
pretty well but the point here is that
this person believes that they did
something good
in fact this person bailey actually put
up
a note online saying quote ambushing
tucker carlson while he is in a store
with his family he's sorry he says he he
put up a a note
in which he explained how wonderful he
was for
having done this in the first place on
his instagram
right saying that it's not often that
you get a chance to do something like it
says it's not every day
you get to tell someone they are the
worst person in the world and really
mean it what an ahole this man has
killed more people with vaccine
misinformation he has supported extreme
racism
he is a fascist and does more to rip
this country apart than anyone that
calls themselves an american
okay so i have a question what let's try
and get in his head for a second
the the person who who ambushes tucker
carlson in public here what does he
think he's accomplishing
like really does he think that if he
ambushes tucker carlson and yells at him
in front of his daughter that somehow
tucker is going to stop doing
what he does on the air on a nightly
basis does he think that he is going to
achieve some sort of magical
illumination for tucker where tucker
suddenly switches all of his positions
and becomes a rabid joe biden supporter
or starts
supporting all of the various talking
points that this fly fishing guide
wants him to mirror of course not it's
not about convincing tucker carlson
what it is is about the performative
it's about performing for the people
online
it's about performing for the left wing
which sees this sort of stuff as heroism
and people ranging from jamal bowie at
the new york times to half the
establishment media
or putting up headlines treating this as
not only newsworthy but praiseworthy
because this guy is a hero he has stood
up to power and he has said what
so many people unleft want him to say
and what this really is
is mentality that is endangering america
not what tucker says hey you may
disagree with what tucker says
you may think the tucker's wrong some of
the time as an independent human being i
think tucker is wrong sometimes we did
an entire hour-long interview maybe a
couple of years ago
in which he and i disagreed strenuously
on everything from economics to
sometimes even social policy
but that's not the same thing okay
disagreeing with somebody's political
point of view is not the same thing as
what you're seeing here
what you are seeing here it's it's an
authoritarian mindset
it really is the idea that you get to go
up to people and treat them terribly in
front of their children
because they are so politically wrong
and then performatively post that online
and then
have all of your political allies tell
you what a wonderful person you are for
doing this
right again you're not confronting
somebody in a public setting this isn't
tucker carlson on his show it's not even
tucker carlson
walking on the street by himself which
would still not be wonderful but
this is him eating with and you've seen
this sort of thing before he's in a
fishing
fly store a fly fishing store with his
family he said this was sarah huckabee
sanders when she was working for the
trump administration
she was eating at a restaurant you saw
people at the restaurant starting to
harass her and the people throwing her
out of the restaurant
you've seen this with black lives matter
protesters literally going down the
street to restaurants in washington dc
and berating people who are sitting
there eating their dinner
authoritarianism comes in a couple of
forms there's the sort of traditional
authoritarianism which is a centralized
government power
that crams down its viewpoint on you
without regard to your individual rights
and then there is what theodore ardorno
once suggested was the authoritarian
mindset right the authoritarian mind now
dorno
was a marxist and so his suggestion
about what constituted authoritarianism
really more just looked like
conventional conservatism
but there is such a thing as
authoritarianism and it does exist on
the left and it does exist on the right
and it includes the idea that you get to
yell at people and tell them what to do
that your viewpoint is the only
viewpoint and not only that
that all the institutions surrounding a
person and protecting
a person those have to be torn down in
order to benefit
the people and when i see what happened
to tucker i think that that mindset is
extraordinarily prevalent
in today's society and you see it by
polling data by the way if you look on
college campuses the number of kids who
believe that it is okay to shout down a
speaker
not to go and ask questions not to
protest outside to go into an event and
shut down a speaker is very high
the number of students who say that it's
okay to report a professor for saying
something quote unquote controversial
in many cases a majority and people feel
this right people can feel this
and i have a brand new book out it comes
out tomorrow it's called the
authoritarian moment
and this is something that i talk about
is is this this new mindset
that is predominant on the left but that
has institutional support because again
the mindset that you get to tell
everybody else what to do and that
everybody else who disagrees with you
ought to be excised from polite society
that exists on all sides of the aisle
the question is where is the
institutional support
and the answer is the institutional
support for this exists on the left
it exists on the left okay this is not
remember joe the plumber was ripped up
and down his life investigated and he
was torn apart
by the left-wing media for the sin of
barack obama walking onto his driveway
and him asking barack obama about tax
policy
remember this that was treated by the
media the way
that this really should be treated by
the media which is you don't get to go
out
into the public sphere and then find a
private person who happens to be walking
around with their family and then harass
the living crap out of them you don't
get to do that is a bad thing for the
country
the villain in this case is dan bailey
the villain in this case is not tucker
carlson even if you disagree
with tucker carlson and people can feel
this
so there's an excerpt from my book that
was posted in the new york post again
it's called the authoritarian moment it
comes out tomorrow
you should go pre-order a copy today
because it could run out
and it is that popular thank god here is
what i write in the book
more than six in 10 americans say they
fear saying what they think
including a majority of liberals 64
moderates fully 77 percent of
conservatives
only self-described strong liberals feel
confident in saying what they believe
these days to be a left-wing
authoritarian
is to feel the certainty of
anti-conventionalism which means you
believe that your viewpoint
is the only moral viewpoint because
you're anti-conventional you're ripping
down the conventional
the passion of top-down censorship the
belief that you should be able to shut
people up
using all the institutional powers that
be and the thrill of revolutionary
aggression of feeling like you get to
confront like you get to tear down
the maxing waters get in their face yell
at them make their life miserable
phenomenon tomorrow belongs to the
far-left authoritarians to the rest of
us a society run by left-wing
authoritarians is extraordinarily
burdensome
it's to be surrounded by institutional
hatred if you're a conservative or
merely non-leftist in america the hatred
is palpable
they hate you in academia they hate you
in the media they hate you on the sports
field in the movies on facebook and
twitter your boss hates you your
colleagues hate you at least
they have been told that they should and
they hate you because you think the
wrong way
hey this is what so many americans are
feeling and it's not people who are just
thinking like tucker
it is people all the way up to including
mainstream liberals
perhaps the problem is that you attend
church regularly perhaps it's that you
want to run your business and be left
alone
perhaps it's that you want to raise your
kids with traditional social values
it could be that you believe that men
and women exist or that the police are
not generally racist
or that children deserve a mother and a
father or that hard work pays off
or that the american flag stands for
freedom rather than oppression or that
people should be judged based on the
content of their character
rather than the color of their skin
maybe it's that you haven't put your
preferred pronouns in your twitter
profile or hashtag with the latest pride
symbol for the latest cause or use the
proper emoji
in your text messages or maybe it's that
you have friends or family members or
even acquaintances
who have violated any of the thicket of
cultural regulations placed upon us by
our supposed moral betters
guilt by association is just as damning
as guilt through action or
inaction is what i write in my new book
the authoritarian moment this is true
if you watch tucker carlson you could be
confronted the same way as tucker
carlson was confronted in this fly
fishing store and the
blue checks on twitter or of the far
left disproportionately they will cheer
they will think that
you are the bad guy and the person
confronting you and yelling at you is
the good guy
the reasons they hate you i write are
legion they change day to day
one day you might be a ballyhoot
champion of justice for standing up for
gay rights or feminist ideals
the next day you might be told you have
been banished for your refusal to
acknowledge that a man calling himself a
woman
is not in fact a woman martina
navratilova or jk rowling
one day you might find yourself a hero
of the intelligentsia for your cynicism
about religion the next
you might find yourself a villain for
the great sin of suggesting that cancel
culture breeds radicalization
like sam harris or stephen pinker this
is not a question of democrat or
republican
not one figure named above would
identify as a republican let alone a
conservative
there's only one thing in the end that
unites the disparate figures deemed
worthy of the gulag in our ongoing
culture war
refusal the standards matter less than
the simple message you will comply
and you will like it and that is the
feeling that so many people have
there are a lot of everyday americans
who are not powerful
in the media the way that tucker carlson
is powerful in the media who feel
that they are at risk of the same sort
of ostracization socially
and treatment publicly that tucker was
subjected to when he just went
to a fly fishing store in montana of all
places
and this has been a long time boiling
under the
sort of veneer of american society
always social disapproval
has incredible consequences for people
but when social disapproval
becomes not only something that you use
when somebody is way outside the
boundaries
of the overton window but it's something
that is used frequently
routinely it's encouraged it's good
social
you have to be part of the social
ostracizing crowd or be its target
once that happens the society's in deep
trouble
and now there are a lot of people on on
the left and some people who are
quote-unquote consider themselves on the
so-called moderate right who say that
really this is not a problem right
cultural authoritarianism this way it's
you know you're exaggerating it's not a
big deal there's no such thing as cancel
culture
this is what woke rulers assure us while
busily hunting down our most
embarrassing political faux pas
there's nothing wrong they say with
calling your boss to try to get you
fired after all that's the free market
working
why are you whining about social media
censorship or about social ostracism
people have a right to tear to shreds to
end your career to malign your character
it's all free speech and in a certain
sense they're not wrong
your boss does have the right to fire
you your friends and family do have a
right to cut you off
none of that amounts to a violation of
the first amendment as i write my book
it simply amounts to the end of the
republic
free speech and free exchange of ideas
die when the attitude of philosophical
tolerance withers
writing in 1831 the greatest observer of
america and democracy alexis de
tocqueville sums up the threat of
democratic despotism in terms that sound
shockingly and eerily prescient quote if
you crave the vote of your fellow
citizens they will not grant it to you
if you demand only their esteem they
will still pretend to refuse it to you
you shall remain among men you shall
lose your rights of humanity when you
approach those like you they shall flee
you as being impure
those who believe in your innocence even
they shall abandon you for one
would flee them in their turn okay the
this is the this is the problem okay
what happened to tucker is indicative of
something broader that's happening in
american society
and that is for political gain the
attempt to run roughshod over your
fellow citizen and treat them not as an
individual worthy of dignity and human
rights
but treat them as an opponent to be
crushed in front of their children
you can't have a country this way you
really cannot regardless of what you
think
of anything that tucker has to say we'll
get some more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact you really don't need to
go to the post office ever now i like
the post office i think it's great
there's a lot of great services but you
really want to wait in line at the post
office with all the other humans when
you could just do everything at home
go to stamps.com today here at dailywire
we've been using stamps.com
since 2017 no more wasting our time
stamps.com brings the same us postal and
ups shipping services directly to your
computer
they make it easy for small businesses
to ship and mail without needing to take
a trip to the post office at all you can
print official u.s postage and shipping
labels 24 7
without having to leave your desk or buy
any fancy equipment all you need
is your computer and standard printer
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or
drop it off it is that simple stamps.com
it's a no-brainer saving nearly 1
million small business owners like you
time and money they offer deals you
can't get anywhere else like up to 40
percent off usps and up to 66
off ups shipping rates with their switch
and save feature you can quickly compare
carriers and find the best rates
every single time i love anything that
saves us time and money here at daily
wire because hey
i own part of the business you should do
the same with your personal mail and
with your business mail stop wasting
time going to the post office go to
stamps.com
instead no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus
free postage and digital skill no long
term commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office
again okay so here's the thing once you
start targeting
tucker publicly you can see
how this quickly moves into the realm of
targeting officially
there's a bleed up that happens in
american politics things that start at a
societal level eventually crystallize
and become government policy because if
it's okay to target somebody socially
pretty soon there are a lot of people
nodding and giggling when somebody is
targeted governmentally
so you remember that tucker carlson went
on the air maybe a month ago
six weeks ago and he said that the nsa
had been reading his text in his emails
and a lot of people poo-pooed that they
were like oh that's not happening that's
silly
he said that the nsa was targeting him
now what i suggested is that the nsa may
not have been quote unquote targeting
him what they may have done
is they may have caught up his
communications in a sweep but that if
they unmasked him
meaning they looked for his identity
which you're not supposed to do with
domestic american citizens
then we would have a problem and it
appears that that is what is going on
according to the new york post the
national security
security agency has quietly admitted
that the identity of fox news primetime
host tucker carlson was quote unquote
unmasked and leaked as he alleged
earlier this month according to a report
for the nsa to unmask tucker carlson or
any journalist attempting to secure a
newsworthy interview is entirely
unacceptable and raises
serious questions about their activities
as well as their original denial which
was wildly misleading a fox news
spokesperson told the record a cyber
security news site
two sources told the record on friday
that according to an internal nsa
investigation
carlson's name was revealed after it was
mentioned in communications between two
parties who were under surveillance
but the host of tucker carlson tonight
was neither a direct nor an incidental
target of the agency
the sources said so that means that they
were not actually targeting him but they
were unmasking his identity now
typically you only unmask somebody's
identity if they're a domestic american
citizen if that person is suspected of
being involved in illegal activity or if
you need to know their identity in order
to prosecute and pursue
foreign illegal activity typically you
don't unmask american citizens you
remember that this was something that
happened with regard to michael flynn
and michael flynn was unmasked by the
obama administration for no apparent
reason
the use of the intelligence apparatus in
order to unmask american citizens
who really are posing no national
security threat to these serious
problems but you're not seeing
anybody scream and shout about any of
this in the left-wing media i promise
you if the trump administration
were busily unmasking everybody who'd
ever booked an interview with a foreign
actor
while trump was president this of course
would have been a problem but tucker
it's okay
it's not a big deal and by the way it's
the same thing with regard to
all it's not just with regard to people
like tucker it's also true
with regard to for example propublica
releasing irs records on a wide bevy of
rich americans rich people
are bad therefore it's okay that
propublica is illegally obtaining
records and then publishing them
none of this is okay a functioning
republic has to have
neutral rules of equal applicability
you cannot have a republic where some
people are treated as
social outcasts to the point not only
where them expressing kind of normal
political opinions means that they are
treated as as lepers in social society
and yelled at publicly but also that the
government targets them and everybody
just goes eh
eh if you're a good american citizen you
need to defend the rights of your
opponents just as much as you defend
your own rights this used to be like a
normal thing that we all believed
but now i guess this has gone completely
by the wayside
and i i think the reason for that is
that politics has become
expressive rather than about problem
solving you can see this
in the way that people talk about
politics generally in the united states
no longer are we worried about problem
solving now we are worried about whether
politicians express sympathy
we have an empathetic president
president joe biden and that matters
much more
than all of the bad policy that he's
pursuing and we are looking
for for people in politics and politics
is really about
expressing your feeling of solidarity
with people it is not about whether the
policy is good or bad
it is not about whether policy is
helpful or harmful
it's in my own marriage we have a rule
in my marriage that we try to
cue to okay and this rule is pretty
simple when my wife and i start a
conversation
and she brings up a problem i will ask
her is this a is this a problem
where you want me to offer solutions or
is this a problem where you just want me
to hear how you're feeling
and thankfully my wife is rational
enough to go along with that
and the reason this is useful is because
if you're married if you're in a
relationship you know that very often
these two conversations get conflated
and that if you offer a solution in a
feelings conversation you are now
considered unfeeling
this happens in marriage all the time
right your wife comes home she had a bad
day at work and she says you know i want
to tell you about all these problems i'm
having at work you say you know what you
could
do is this this and this and she says
that's not what i don't want to hear
your solutions i don't need your
solutions i know i can do those things
what i want is for you to just hear me i
just want you to hear now politics is
not supposed to be like that
and politics is supposed to be here is a
problem now let's figure out a solution
but politics is no longer about that
because we are such an expressive
society and because we have wrapped up
our own personal identities in our
politics
this means that if somebody offers you a
solution to your problem
that fails to recognize your emotional
state that person is now a problem
that person is now an enemy if that
person engages in solutions talk rather
than feelings talk
that person ought to be ostracized that
person
is the problem you can see this in a
wide variety of
areas in american life it's particularly
true when it comes to areas like race
for example
our great racial reckoning is not about
coming up with solutions
that actually boost the the performance
of for example black school children it
is not about that
it is not about coming up with policies
that are best geared
toward rectifying historic imbalances
it's not about that
what it is about is expressing the
belief that the united states is bad
expressing solidarity with the belief
that the united states is bad
and if you refuse to express that
solidarity then you're the problem
in fact if you refuse to go along with
the policy agenda that is
really just empathy in terms of policy
if you refuse to go along with that then
you're a bad person
the conflation of empathy with policy is
one of the worst things that can happen
in our political sphere and it is
happening each and every day because
that means that people for whom you are
empathetic deserve your help and people
for whom you are not empathetic do not
it also means that policy
is simply supposed to be interpreted as
a sign of empathy rather than as a
measure of success
or problem solving and that is a real
real problem
in american society okay so let's let's
talk about race
for a second okay so over the weekend
there are a couple of interviews about
race and our quote-unquote racial
reckoning that were quite telling and
kind of fascinating
and again policy has now been conflated
with empathy which creates two separate
problems
one is that if your policy solves
but is not rooted in a belief that the
person's feelings are justified
then you are unempathetic and bad the
policy itself is bad
so we judge policy by whether it is
empathetic
also we judge whether you are empathetic
by the policy you choose
so if you choose a policy that is not
rooted in empathy
you are bad so there are two separate
problems with
conflating empathy and policy one is bad
policy
and one is the is the targeting of
people who disagree with you on policy
as non-empathetic
and both of these things are now a
routine part of american politics and it
helps explain
why so many americans hate other
americans based on their political
viewpoint because you might think to
yourself
wait a second they're usually more than
one way to skin a deer here like there
are a couple of different ways to
approach this problem
i'm offering a solution you offer
another solution we don't seem to be
able to come to an agreement about that
but
why don't we try and see whose solution
is better that's not how politics is
done anymore
the overt conflation of empathy and
policymaking
it's the worst thing for both empathy
and policymaking it makes you less
empathetic to people who think not like
you
and it makes your policy worse because
your policy is now just
an expression of how much you care okay
so when it comes to race you can see
this most of all because there are
certain policies
that are likely to facilitate for
example better performance
those policies include things like
standardized testing
standardized testing is an incentive
structure that causes people to try to
perform
up to tests treating people as
individuals is an excellent way
of rectifying social imbalances why
because if you treat people as
individuals then everybody is held to
the same standard
and then i'm not judging you based on
your race or group identity i'm judging
you based on whether you hit these
objective metrics
how do we know that these sorts of
neutral policies
are excellent for the country and
excellent for people who have
historically been dispossessed in the
united states
because for a wide variety of minority
groups these have been the ladders to
success
it's it's neutrality that has provided
the ladders to success for jews for
example who are not treated as a group
who are originally treated as a group
but no longer are right or treated as
individuals
based on performance we judge whether
you've done well in american society the
same thing is true of asian americans
but when it comes to the divides between
black and white because america does
have a history
of treating black people as a group and
treating them horribly up through the
end of jim crow
because of that there's this idea that
even
that going back to the same tools that
have worked for every minority group
gaining
power gaining gaining financial success
getting educational success that it just
doesn't apply to black people now
you have to explain why it wouldn't
apply to black people and they're only
two explanations one is
you are unempathetic right this is the
explanation of the left you're not
empathetic to the experience of black
americans
and this is why you don't understand
that the latter that's been used by
every single minority group in the
united states
does not apply to black people it just
doesn't apply and this is the argument
of robin d'angelo and edward mx kennedy
if you use neutral rules then you are
actually doing something to harm black
americans because you are unempathetic
right that is one of the arguments that
is made and the other
is that you refuse to acknowledge your
own racism it's really about you
it's not about trying to solve the
problem it's about you and your lack of
empathy
and your lack of empathy is because you
don't understand the problem or you wish
not to understand the problem
because again policy is now secondary
empathy is key in politics empathy
should never be key
policy should always be key because how
you feel on the inside has no bearing on
whether your policy is good or not
there is not a single human being who
has ever implemented a policy on planet
earth
who believed they were implementing an
evil policy
the most evil people on the on the
planet right now today
believe they are implementing policy
that quote unquote helps people
it is not about intent it is not about
empathy it is about whether the policy
is in effect good
and whether the policy can be morally
justified on the basis of respecting
individual human beings
but we've lost that in the united states
so on race particularly we've lost this
because again the the left agenda with
regard to race and the left's
quote-unquote empathy with regard to
race requires you to think of people as
member of groups
rather than as individuals and so what
this ends with is we need to teach your
kids in school
that they're a member of a different
group from black people and that they
are in fact the subjugators of black
people
and if they were and if they call for
things like neutral rules or
treating people like individuals that is
merely re-enshrining hierarchies of
power
and if you refuse to go along with this
kind of garbage indoctrination that is
immoral in its essence
this means that you are a racist so
alexander ocasio-cortez said this pretty
openly over the weekend
it's funny you have all these critical
race theorists out there saying no no
it's all it's more sophisticated than
that we're not teaching your kids that
they're racist
it's not about that we're teaching them
that the structures of power are racist
okay but here's alexandra ocasio-cortez
who's basically letting the cat out of
the back she's like no no we're teaching
your kids that they're racist and if
they refuse to acknowledge that they're
racist
this is just a demonstrative of the fact
that they are unempathetic and therefore
racist
so why don't republicans want
us to learn how to not be racist
why don't republicans want us want kids
to know
how to not be racist
why don't republicans want us to know
how to not be racist because your
definition of racist
is not about individual intent your
isn't even about whether black people
are better off or worse off under your
policies
your definition of racist is do they
mirror my policy preferences which are
the only empathetic policy preferences
because my policy preferences are a
substitute for success
politics is not the game of empathy but
it has become the game of empathy
i think this can be applied broadly
right robin d'angelo who's made an
amazing living being just an
unbelievable racial grifter
over the weekend she says that even
comedy is an excuse to be racist
right because again if everything is
about empathy then we can't have things
like you can make fun of everybody
that's unempathetic
now that makes us less free now free
human beings make jokes about lots of
people including people of other groups
people make jewish jokes honestly it
really doesn't bother me
as a general rule it really does not
bother me because human beings make fun
of each other all the time that is just
an aspect it's one of the more joyful
aspects of being human by the way
a lot of group jokes i find you know
inappropriate and ugly but
when i quash the ability of people to
tell jokes i mean robin d'angelo what
it's a humorless society they're
creating here
so comedy is um
[Music]
i think it's an excuse to get to be
racist right like
irony and i think tv shows like family
guy and
um south park and maybe a little bit the
simpsons right
allowed white people to be racist
self-consciously
and and there is a concept in comedy
called punching up not
down so you know you want to punch up
there's very different power dynamics
and and it it doesn't hurt in the same
way
it doesn't invoke a deep deep
centuries-long
history of oppression when you when you
poke fun at say
white people but it's very very
different when you poke fun
at people of color so the only people
you're allowed to make fun of are people
who are white right you have to think of
each other in terms of groups this
demonstrates
your empathy and this is how we
determine policy now
policy is not about whether it
accomplishes its fact it's about whether
you're empathetic now there are people
who i genera
like they're people who i'm friends with
i think have fallen into this trap of
conflating policy making
and empathy as though these are the same
thing one of those people is david
french so
i consider myself a pretty good friend
with david franchit i talked to
david fairly frequently although not as
much recently he has a piece that i
think
is worthy of consideration under this
rubric because i think that you are
seeing
moderate america slide into this morass
whereby empathy and
policymaking are considered one and the
same and this is particularly true on
the issue of race so he has a piece in
the dispatch
called structural racism isn't wokeness
it's reality
hey now it depends how you define
structural racism as i've said many many
times
okay when we talk about institutional
racism or white privilege
or structural racism what are we talking
about are we talking about the
structures of america
perpetuate racism today or are we
talking about history has consequences
and for all of human history you have
inherited problems that your parents had
and then you've had to deal with those
problems this has been true literally
for all time and will always continue to
be true history has consequences we all
know that
so which are we talking about the
conflation of the two is really
dangerous because if the idea is that
history has created imbalances but that
the institutions of society
have to be changed on a fundamental
level now even though they are not
racist
in order to rectify those historic
problems
the institutions now must be made
unequal and discriminatory
in order to rectify those historic
problems what you are doing is
perpetuating a new problem
now you have made the institutions
themselves discriminatory
as a substitute for empathy right you
have made the policy geared
not toward equality under the law not in
individual freedoms and human rights
instead you've geared the policy toward
quote unquote fixing problems in the
past based on group empathy you can have
empathy for people who have been members
of groups you can have empathy for
individuals who have had to live with
the burden of for example not inheriting
as much wealth from their parents or
grandparents
right that's that's worthy of empathy
but does that mean that the way to
rectify that is to treat people as of
particular racial groups as inherent
victims of the society today
it seems not empathy and policymaking
again are not the same thing
but david french goes further than that
and and i find this bewildering because
if you read david's writing from even
three or four years ago it was
almost completely converse to this you
can recognize the the problems of
historic injustice
without suggesting the systems need to
be torn down
so here's what david writes today he
says
he's talking about a a problem within
major churches the the southern baptist
conventions international
mission board for example this basically
all these major churches
are now having problems in which there
are sort of leaders
of these churches who have started to
mimic and mirror
many of the many of the policy
viewpoints
and philosophical descriptions of the
critical race theory movement
he says this is david french the
congregant subjects what they perceive
as a pastoral embrace
of critical race theory they assert that
the bible alone contains
teaching sufficient to address america's
race problems you can read the
comprehensive complaint against a guy
named david platt and his team here
and the allegations of teaching or
advocating crt in another place without
restating
all the contents of these lengthy
documents include complaints that platt
and his mbc colleague pastor mike kelsey
nbc is the mclean bible church marched
in a christian black lives matter march
and that kelsey has endorsed the crt
concepts of systemic racism and white
privilege
they also condemn plat for this comment
which argues that the absence of over
prejudice does not absolve one of the
problems of racism and racialization
quote
a disparity exists we can't deny this
these are not opinions they're facts
it matters in our country whether one is
white or black now we don't want it to
matter which is why i think we try to
convince ourselves it doesn't matter we
think to ourselves i don't hold
prejudices toward black or white people
so racism is not my problem
but this is where we need to see that
racialization is our problem
it's all of our problem we subtly almost
unknowingly contribute to it
okay well there's there are many
problems with this statement that are
put forward here
by again mike kelsey or rather david
platt
okay so the the mere fact of a disparity
does not imply that discrimination is
responsible
solely for the disparity it could be
that discrimination is it could be
historic discrimination is it
or it could be that people make
different decisions those different
decisions have different consequences
and we need to incentivize better
decision making thus to ensure better
consequences
it could be that it could also be that
while there is undoubtedly imbalances
there are undoubtedly imbalances that
have been inherited from the past it
could be
it could also be that the solution to
that is not
to get rid of again neutral laws of
equal applicability
right the solution to that is to
acknowledge that that is just the way
that life works that that is unfairness
and the best way to rectify the unfair
fairness is not to perpetuate new
unfairness but but david i think slides
here
and and gets in some pretty dicey
territory he says the dissenters argue
that the solution to the race problem in
america is more bible not more sociology
books
it is not the bible plus a secular
reading list but solo scriptura
it's not just unwise to rely on secular
scholarship to address american racism
they argue it's unbiblical now there's
some truth to this
and when people say that the solution to
what what ails us is
treating people well individually they
are correct about this
they are correct especially in a in a
country where
legal discrimination is actively
forbidden by the federal state and local
government
yes we need more god yes we need more
bible and yes we need to treat each
other as individual human beings better
now recently i was talking to a group of
liberal folks and they were talking
about polarization in the society and
how can we solve it together
i said i have a very simple solution
really it's very very simple every one
of you because these are some prominent
folks on the left
i said every one of you go online
tonight
on twitter find somebody who voted for
trump who you know and personally like
and say
i know this person voted for trump i
disagree they're a good person and i
respect him as a human
say that polarization goes away
overnight but that is not the point they
won't do it that's unempathetic
the empathy is unempathetic we'll get to
more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about getting in shape so
i know some people lost weight during
the pandemic some people gain weight
during the pandemic i will say the
people who lost weight it's because they
had great home exercise and one of those
things
is echelon echelon is the affordable way
to get workout equipment
the workout community and an
instructor's motivation right
in the comfort of your own home
echelon's fitness app provides you
thousands of live and on-demand classes
with great music from your favorite
artists with echelon it can work out
anytime day or night and accomplish your
fitness goals just pick your class climb
the leaderboard cheer each other on and
give it your all
echelon's certified fitness instructors
are supportive engaging and fun they
really know how to get you moving
echelon's full range of affordable
workout equipment including stationary
bikes smart rollers
sleek fitness screens or the auto
folding treadmill they're all connected
to provide the echelon
experience they've got around the clock
classes for the family including the
full body workout programs to keep you
coming back
one membership will cover a family of
five it's awesome okay i've been using
echelon myself you wanna
know why it looks so felt and magical
these days it's because echelon
absolutely works right now
get an echelon ex3 bike risk free for 30
days plus free shipping and assembly to
get this exclusive offer with those free
bonuses valued at 250 bucks go to
echelonfit.com that's
e-c-h-e-l-o-n-f-i-t dot com slash ben
for this free offer again that's
echelonfit.com
ben go check them out right now and get
in the shape you've always wanted to be
in
slash echelonfit.com all right we'll get
some more on this in just one second
first
if you haven't pre-ordered a signed copy
of my newest book the authoritarian
moment you're running out of time
mentioning it all day and it's hitting
bookshelves tomorrow tuesday july 27th
get your limited edition signed book
right now
for just 30 bucks at dailywire.com
pretty good deal if you ask me i've been
signing books like
crazy especially because i will be doing
a live stream book signing and q a
tomorrow you can submit a question right
now when you go to purchase your
assigned copy when you do
you'll be asked to type in a question to
check out then catch tomorrow's live
signing see if i answer your question
watch me sign
your book if i don't get to your
question don't worry you'll still
receive your signed copy so what exactly
are you waiting for
add to your collection go to
dailywire.comband
right now also we here at dailywear
we're really excited we've just launched
our newest podcast morning wire it's
already the number two podcast on apple
it's number 11 on spotify why is it
doing so well because it's a daily news
podcast that values your time and the
truth
while we're proud of sticking to our
values and what that can accomplish we
need you to help us
get the news you need to know where it
belongs at number one so subscribe right
now to morningwire on applespotify or
wherever you listen to podcast leave a
five star review if you like
what you hear the show is brought to you
by daily wire editor and chief john
bickley co-host georgia howe morningwire
will wake you up with the latest
developments in politics
sports culture and education all with a
heavy emphasis on the facts
in 15 bite size minutes perfect for your
daily commute i've been listening to it
it's great
i tend to listen to it at like two time
speeds you can get through all the news
in like seven and a half minutes it's
fantastic again
subscribe to morning wire on apple
podcast spotify everywhere you listen to
podcasts so you don't miss a beat if you
like what you hear
leave a five star review tell the
podcast platform's conservative news
belongs at number one on the charts
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so we're talking again about the
equation of empathy
and and policy making in politics
and how this has led to the idea that if
somebody disagrees with you on policy
you can confront them in a fly fishing
store and yell at them to the wild
cheers of the blue checked media
and again there's a piece from my friend
david french over at the dispatch
that i think is actually not a good
piece and actually quite telling as to
how people fall into the ideological
trap of conflating empathy and
policymaking it's all about race and he
is talking about how in the christian
community there's been a pushback
against
critical race theory he says
that there that under this mode of
thinking the critics of critical race
theory
the concept of equality under the law as
mandated by the constitution and the
civil rights act is both necessary and
largely sufficient to address the causes
and consequences
of centuries of slavery followed by
generations of jim crow no that's not
the argument
the argument is not that the
constitution and the civil rights act
the 14th amendment and equality under
law
that those are sufficient to address the
consequences
of history because nothing will ever be
sufficient to address the consequences
of history
i mean truthfully there is no way that
you can repay people
for their great great great grandparents
being enslaved
how exactly do you repay that there's no
way i mean how how do you
like the notion of reparations is in and
of itself the concept
is is somewhat insulting in the sense
that there is no way to actively repair
the kinds of damages that have been done
to people over time when people talk
about holocaust reparations
if the german government signed somebody
80 grand like their grandkid 80 grand
because grandma got gassed at the age of
or grandma got gas at the age of 20.
okay then then sorry that that is not a
reparation right
that may be a payoff and it may be
something that is an attempt at
reparation but it is not an actual
reparation and
no one is arguing that equality under
law is the is the thing
that makes up for the past oh we're
saying it's the only ladder to success
in american society and it's the only
ladder back to anything remote
remotely approaching civility and and
political consonants there's only one
way the country comes back together and
that's if the same rules apply to all of
us
but says david french no that's wrong
this is on the core issues of american
racism
this pastor david platt is biblically
and historically right it's his
detractors who are biblically and
historically wrong
these conservatives have placed a
secular political frame around an issue
with profound religious significance
they've thus not just abandoned the
whole council of scripture they've even
contradicted
a core component of the secular
conservatism they claim to uphold
and then he cites the bible and he talks
about the fact that in the bible there
are certain
soul situations where there is blood
guilt on particular people
now there are a couple of contradictory
verses in the bible seemingly
contradictory verses one
is that god revisits payments on the
third and fourth generations
now to my ears what that sounds like is
god recognizing that history has
consequences
in the bible that if you do something
there will be consequences to the third
and fourth generation but the bible
unlike for example old mesopotamian law
like the code of hammurabi says that you
are not allowed to punish a child for
the sins of
their father you're not allowed to do
that by the law there is a difference
between how god judges the universe and
how we are supposed to judge the
children of people who sinned in the
past
and the only way we can have a society
moving forward is to treat everyone
by the exact same rules but david seems
to be straying from that here
right he says that we have to confess
our sins so he he says it's our job to
confess
the sins of the past because for example
in the book of second kings josiah tore
his clothes and wept when the high
priest found the book of the law
neglected in the temple why
josiah said quote because our fathers
have not obeyed the words of this book
and in the book of nehemiah the
israelites confess the sins and
iniquities of their fathers in the book
of leviticus god commanded the
israelites to confess the iniquity and
inequity of their fathers
okay so i can confess these sins of
people who have come before me in the
united states
that does not mean that you get to
subject my children to disparate
treatment
or me that's not how any of that works
again this is the conflation of empathy
with policy i can have full empathy for
people who suffer because in
in the past their family was victimized
that does not change the fact that if
they wish to rise to any level of
success in american society they have to
use the exact same ladder that has
been provided and is provided to every
individual in the united states
and that's been particularly true for
the last half century
but but again once you get to the point
where the policy is the empathy you get
into really ugly territory because the
converse is if you disagree with me on
policy you deserve no empathy and if you
just
you deserve no empathy we can target you
as much as we could possibly want
and this lies behind so much of our
politics these days it's not about
problem solving
it's about othering people it is not
about problem solving and getting to yes
it is about treating people who disagree
with you as though they are the problem
as though they are not only wrong but
foolish idiots who must be controlled
from above okay so this has consequences
for a lot of various issues in our
society
it has consequences for example when it
comes to covid so
let's say that you wish to convince
people that they ought to get vaccinated
so i found out recently that a lot of
people in our office people i work with
are not vaccinated as you know
i'm a very large-scale proponent of
vaccination i've been a proponent of
vaccinations since the beginning
i've been in proponents of vaccinations
since way before covet it's one of
my more controversial views among
conservatives i'm very pro-vaccination
okay but a lot of people in this office
didn't get vaccinated
they're independent free human beings if
i wanted to get them vaccinated i would
treat them as independent free human
beings i would mention the fact
that covid has higher risk factors than
getting the vaccine
by all available data for people who are
above the age of 18 for sure for people
who are above the age of 12 that seems
to be the case as well
okay and that being the case you now get
to make an independent and free decision
but this is not how
people of the left are approaching the
problem the way they're approaching the
problem
is that if you didn't get the vaccine
it's not because you made a differential
risk reward calculation for which you
ought to bear the consequences notice
my solution also not only encompasses
treating people as individual free human
beings it also suggests
that you ought to bear the consequences
of the risk you are taking
if you choose to take a risk bear the
consequences same rules for everybody
same exact rules for everybody i got the
vaccine my wife got the vaccine my
parents got the vaccine and now we bear
the risk
of the vaccine and if you don't get the
vaccine you bear the risk of the vaccine
same rule
for every single human being and you get
to make that decision yourself because
you're a free independent human being
but the way the left treats this
is you're morally inferior if you didn't
get the vaccine
not just that you're an idiot but you're
endangering other people's lives you're
a bad person
now even if you believe that that's the
case is that the way to treat fellow
human beings
really like on a serious level is that
the way that you think you're going to
convince them to do things remember the
guy who shouted at hunter carlson was
not interested in convincing tucker
carlson to change his opinion
he was interested in virtue signaling to
all of his friends this is the same
thing in the media today it's the same
thing from for example
anthony fauci right so anthony fauci the
great and sainted second greatest doctor
in america after dr joe biden he says
you know
maybe we should blame people maybe that
will work or maybe it won't
maybe it won't maybe you should look
inward a little bit
use a little bit of introspection and
realize the reason that nobody trusts
anthony fauci is because he has been
institutionally wrong
at nearly every level of this pandemic
repeatedly
i generally don't like to get involved
in blaming people because i think that
would maybe push them back even more
rather than i mean i could totally
understand the governor's frustration so
i don't have any problem with that she
has every right to be frustrated but
what i would really like to see
is more and more of the leaders in those
areas
that are not vaccinating to get out and
speak out and encourage people to get
vaccinated
i don't want to blame people but if they
get blamed well you know that's the way
that john lemon is even
is way worse obviously don lemon is the
worst at all of this on cnn
he says that everyone who's not getting
vaccinated they're idiotic they're
nonsensical okay here's the thing
even if you believe that is that going
to convince anybody or is that really
much more
about treating somebody as morally
lesser
it's the people who are the greatest
proponents of empathy it turns out are
really not empathetic for anybody who
disagrees with them
and and here's the thing when we're
talking about vaccines that have this
high level of
efficacy and when we are living in a
time where people are bearing the
consequences of their own
decision-making
it seems to me that now would be an
excellent time to say listen
right now we're having a pandemic the
pandemic continues among the
unvaccinated
the unvaccinated have exactly the same
risk factors they had when they were
dying by the thousands
back in january and so if you choose to
make that decision
you bear the risk you do if you're
vaccinated you're doing pretty well
these days
if you're unvaccinated you're probably
not doing nearly as well so probably
should get vaccinated but
your decision wouldn't that be a better
way to convince people than shouting at
them that they're idiots
but here's dunlap and shouting at people
that they're idiots
i've heard over the last couple of days
that you know you shouldn't be
um you don't say bad things about people
who don't get the vaccine because then
they'll feel like you're attacking them
or whatever but
michael how much more would you kind of
call it what it is
if if behavior is idiotic
and nonsensical i think that you need to
tell people that their behavior is
idiotic and nonsensical
doesn't mean that they are idiots is
this that their behavior in
on this particular point that is not
making sense
just going to note here that according
to don lemon medically speaking it is
fully idiotic and nonsensical for a 20
year old to consider the risk-reward
calculation with regard to a vaccine
you can't say that anything is idiotic
and nonsensical about a 20-year-old
trying to completely mutilate their body
to look like a member of the opposite
gender and then calling themselves a
member of the opposite gender
right that's that no that that's that's
medically appropriate and if you doubt
that that's medically appropriate
then it's because you're a bigot just a
quick note there on medicine
circa cnn 2021. but here's the broader
point with regard to all of this
when politics becomes just a game of
treating the other person
as though they are they are undeserving
of empathy on an individual level and
that policy is just an expression
of that empathy you end up in some
pretty bad territory
and that and again the reverse is true
as well it is an excuse for bad policy
making one of the things that we've seen
with regard to the pandemic right now
and we are seeing it
right now is that we actually have a
solution to the pandemic
and the solution to the pandemic is you
learn to live with it
it's a solution that's always been
available the problem is the left
rejected that solution so now
when the pandemic is rearing its ugly
head again they have to control people
because in in the beginning they in
authoritarian fashion shut down
everything they shut down businesses
they maintain the shutdown on businesses
when it became clear that this was
very age stratified and striated when it
became perfectly clear
that people who were 20 were at very
little risk of dying of the virus but
people who were 70 were at very high
risk of dying of the virus
they knew this very early on they still
know that kids are
exorbitantly low risk of dying from the
virus but they're treating it as though
kids are at high risk of dying from the
virus why because again it's about
empathy
right my empathy for society is
demonstrated by the amount of control
that i lavish upon you it's helicopter
politicking
right the more attention i lavish on you
the more i control you top down
the more i'm demonstrating my empathy
well the problem with that is that joe
biden had basically declared the
pandemic was going to be over july 4th
right
it's now the end of july and the
pandemic is not in fact over
it was people on the right are saying
but it is
and when we say it is we don't mean that
people aren't dying in the virus we mean
that the end of a pandemic can logically
be charted to when everybody in a
particular country has the opportunity
to take a cure
which is the vaccine or or not
and then we're done the government
literally has no more role to play here
once you have the ability to get a
problem fixed
and you're not passing that problem on
to other people meaning that
you yourself can protect yourself once
you can protect yourself then this
becomes very much
like you eat too much and you're obese
and you get heart disease it looks a lot
more like that
it's preventable right in this
particular case why are you worried
about people
seriously who are making free decisions
of their own accord not to get
vaccinated
in a free country normally you would say
okay well it's a free country and if
people decide that they are going to do
things that i disagree with that i may
think it's dumb i may think it's
wrong-headed but
they have a right to do that the problem
is that we could have made that solution
last year
ron desantis was very bad in florida for
having engaged in that solution sweden
was a terrible country for having
engaged in that solution
for saying listen you're a young person
you're not a very high risk
you can go out you can live your life if
you're older you should protect yourself
and we should protect you this is what
rhonda santa said he was ripped up and
down because again the height of empathy
was we lock you in your home for months
at a time that was empathetic
it didn't matter whether it worked or
not didn't matter that andrew cuomo
killed all the olds in new york he was
empathetic right he got on tv every
night
and he said things very confidently they
were completely wrong but he was
empathetic and that
was the key okay well now the biden
administration is stuck between a rock
and a hard place because on the one hand
they have done the thing that
technically ends the pandemic namely
they have helped because they used the
trump vaccine and the trump roll out
plan
they have been able to tranch out
hundreds of millions of doses
of the vaccine across the united states
160 million adults in the united states
have taken the vaccine
and meaning that the vast majority of
the adult population above the age of 18
more than 60 percent of the population
above the age of 18 in the united states
has now taken the vaccine and which
means
that technically he should be done right
but he can't be done
it can't be done because to be done
would mean that he's unempathetic
because the policy which started out
empathy was locked down to save every
life
then it became okay well normally you'd
say well no empathy is
providing people with the solutions that
they can use in order to preserve their
own lives
while preserving their freedom that to
me looks a lot more empathetic and
provides a neutral standard by which we
can
allow people to live their own lives but
if empathy is just top down control
if empathy is i am the most empathetic
because
government action is the empathetic
thing then you can't end the pandemic it
can never end
there can never be any end the only way
the pandemic ends is when we have zero
covet
zero covet is never happening and so
instead of the biden administration just
saying listen
you all have the opportunity to what
you're doing we're gonna learn to live
with the virus now if you choose not to
get it disagree think it's bad you
should go get the vaccine
but that's that's on you instead of
doing that he can't do that because to
do that would be to implicitly
acknowledge
that the policies that were pursued last
year were not empathetic and were not
good and were not smart he can't do that
it's zero coveted or nothing for this
administration and so they're stuck
because on the one hand they want to say
look at our magical success in fighting
the virus
on the other hand they can't actually
point to their magical success in
fighting the virus
until they reach the actual end goal
which is we lock down so hard everywhere
in the united states that the virus
completely goes away as a sign
of our empathy i keep looking
at i'm looking at the same stats that
you are and what i come up with is
this the number of deaths in the united
states right now on a daily basis is
so significantly lower than it was even
a few months ago right now if you look
at the chart the
average daily death rate according to
the new york times
i'm looking it up on google right now as
of july 25th the seven day average of
deaths
269. when we were at the height of the
pandemic we were talking about
3 000 300 seven-day running average of
deaths
we are down ten-fold from that and yet
we are treating this as though it's a
crisis the reason we're treating this is
though it's a crisis
even though again the solution is widely
available is because empathy is politics
and politics is empathy
and that's all and if you disagree with
the policy you're not empathetic it's
why the media are focusing in right now
on florida right they say oh look at
this hot spot of florida so many cases
here
right people who are unvaccinated are
getting it and
and true empathy looks like
i treat you as a full independent
individual
human being but we're not going to do
that so here's dr anthony thatcher
saying maybe we will reconsider
forcing the vaccinated to mask which
it's hard to think of something less
empathetic
than we told you to get the vaccine you
did
you did the responsible thing and now we
are going to mask you
and we're going to mask you not because
you're going to pass it on to somebody
who
through no faults of their own could get
the virus we're going to mask you
so the adult down the road who is also a
free individual human being
is protected from a virus for which they
are not protecting themselves it does
not sound empathic to me or the person
who's unvaccinated who's obviously made
an independent human decision that dr
fauci and by the way i
disagree with here is dr fauci though
talking about how true empathy
is authoritarian cram downs do you think
masks should be brought back for
vaccinated americans
you know jake this is under active
consideration the cdc agrees
with that ability and discretion
capability
to say you know you're in a situation
where we're having a lot of dynamics of
infection
so even if you are vaccinated you should
wear a mask that's a local decision
that's not incompatible with the cdc's
overall
recommendations that give a lot of
discretion to the locals
okay again the fact that we are now
talking about more masking more
lockdowns more of this stuff when the
solution is already on the table
it to me it's demonstration not empathy
but the way we have defined empathy is
empathy is
we are going to tell you what to do and
if you don't like it
i guess that you lack empathy and by the
way the solutions now being proposed by
the left are exactly along these lines
you've got the new york times
pushing very hard on the idea that the
only way
to to stop the pandemic is to fight
quote unquote misinformation which is to
crack down on free speech
we saw npr did this last week because by
noah wylan saying in louisiana vaccine
misinformation has public health workers
feeling quote unquote stuck
okay so the only solution there
obviously is top-down censorship you
have to censor the misinformation
and we're going to define misinformation
as anything that
people that the new york times the new
york times agrees with
right if the new york times degree
disagrees with anything it is now
misinformation
and so obviously we need to crack down
on the misinformation
or maybe the problem is the washington
post right the washington post says
the big problem here is that the gop is
moving to limit public health powers
right that what we need to do is more
lockdowns and if you don't wish to see
lockdowns you're unempathetic you want
more people to die
okay well once you get to the point
where you believe that your political
opposition wants more people to die
and the only solution is to silence them
right no more misinformation we got to
stop these gop lawmakers from you know
giving people individual freedoms
we need to stop that that needs to end
right now well then the solution is only
one party rule forever this is how
authoritarianism
bleeds up from attitude toward actual
policy
and it's very ugly stuff alrighty we
will be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael muller
show today
he discusses the olympics flopping in
the ratings you can hear more details
about that story over on michael's show
that's available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021.
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the biden
administration signals a push for
renewed mass
mandates and vaccine boosters australia
erupts in protests after another round
of lockdowns
and the nfl experiences blow back to its
new vaccine rules
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
[Music]
morningwire